[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est là que ça se passe bien on est
tous ça pour que ça se passe bien mais
apportera une chronique où il est
toujours en dessous dans le respect
quand le reste mais bon soir le mans si
ça se marre pas de leurs maux il a
raison si ça se marre pas de leurs mots
je frise la frise
est-ce que vous avez un plus beau j'ai
que lui avaient dit qu'ils avaient tant
mieux ça va dans leur pays ça monte ok
m'obligez pas à faire usage de cette
arme
jean michel tu ne bat acronyme
jean-michel j'étais bien babar a été
volée à lima toi bâtiment à huy entendu
[Rires]
de tout ça marche chez les amish très
heureux de vous accueillir ce soir les
nouveautés petite nouveauté
je ne fasse vous saviez mais moctar a
décidé maintenant il est dans le cinéma
il est devenu acteur je vous le dit momo
qu on a une image regarder quand lucas
à jouer dans un film qui s'appelle daddy
cool non mais c'est quoi ces joueurs
pour mais c'est vrai alors c'est un rôle
à contre-pied sur la vigueur de boîte de
nuit comme ça qu'on l'attendait pas sur
son côté perso c'est une blague patridge
enfin je comprends pas ce délit pas de
rush
enfin mais c'est un bon chiffre
alors dans le calme et donc on a décidé
en fin de chronique
on va lui faire reprendre des très
grands rôles du cinéma il va rejoindre
dans des westerns cultivars jouer dans
gladiator il aura joué dans titanic
petit avant goût là pour vous mettre en
bouche regardez mokhtar qui reprend un
des grands rôles
un des films qui a le plus cartonné en
france 2 toujours regarde alors on
entend par moments c'est très bien ici
mais également sous mais il est dans
matrix également ailleurs on a vu
beaucoup les ailes on a vu beaucoup
laval offre un beau coup valérie bénaïm
dans cette chronique vers elle est
partout celle ci elle nous illumine de
sa beauté
on commence à créer 24 arte tout ce
qu'il fallait pas loupé à la télé
aujourd'hui regardez dehors je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé dans m6 boutique
laurence a complètement pété un boulon
est pas en rap et c'est très gênant rock
sensibles s'abstenir je l'adorais d'une
liste plus vite et de la boutique et
c'est ici c'est maintenant et c'est pas
demain et s'est penché le copain c'est
chez nous envier
au monde rater mois tiens on
s'embrouille dans tellement vrai entre
deux voisines
elle monte dans les tours en une seconde
tout redevient normal on dirait une
embrouille entre gilles et isa ça
redescend vide là tu mélanges fabienne
l'atuge non mais on a des stress je veux
qu'on joue verdon on va jouer la teneur
est ce que tu comprends pas c'est qu'on
a des séquences de société la location
vous l'avez y élève qu'elle fait bien
c'est bon ok bon cette fois pas tenu
pour ce soir j'ai regardé les gîtes
étrangers aussi on est tombé sur la
valeur qui en avaient marre qu'un
journaliste fasse un duplex devant chez
elle va le caractère lavallois pour tous
les parents s'ils voulaient savoir si un
enfant aime à jouer
offrez-lui ce jouet qui mémorise le
visage et on voit qu'il a pas qui c'est
l'enfant
ça veut pas trompé
[Musique]
le jeu est alerte enfants de stars sur
bfm on a vu le fruit de l'union entre
gilles verdez gérard darmon 14 ans
routière des deux sur les adaptations de
film oublie que ces mécanismes à mettre
d'accord les deux donc j'adore cette
attaque lâche c'est magnifique a des
talents franchement c'est beau c'est
réussit rien très fort bravo que petit
col camionneur ça se démoder la balle
bien qu'il faut y aller tu peux y aller
on le sol de passe un cap
oui moi aussi dernier sur le rap
francis letellier ils recevraient la
ministre jacqueline gourault qui a
oublié de bosser sur un dossier la pma à
elle a galéré pendant onze ans pour ne
rien dire au fil des mois pour les
couples de femmes
est ce que vous vous y est favorable
excusez moi je n'ai pas bien compris
votre question favorable à la paix m
avant les coupes du vab
la pma je suis en train de réfléchir aux
relations médicalement assistée oui
c'est ça c'est une question éthique que
j'apporterai ma réponse
qu'on se le sujet viendra chibani fait
pour s'offrir à lui lord auteurs
s'accordent à l'avenir ce serait bien de
couper le micro d'un journaliste en
duplex avant le direct là on en apprend
un petit peu trop sur elle
c'est en savoie pour cette les carottes
course de chiens de traîneaux et des
chiens magnifique on ajoute à leur
ennemi qui coule à linge était en train
d'écouter mais sur ces news une nouvelle
ligne éditoriale visiblement pour eux
soit on est pour les réformes sont là
incompris identifier aussi les autres
sources possibles de financement
alors ce que vous êtes pauvres ce que
vous êtes cons en tout cas vous n'êtes
pas dieu j'attends tunisiens suspects
brad wall il est tous les jours
kelly rowland giachello chalon supplie
de parler d'autres premiers ministres
edouard philippe pasquet le loft trop
élevé le lolo sur instagram bien edouard
viii les bagarres pouvez nous le décrire
tout à fait mais comment il est poussé
comme ci comme ça
il est grand il est beau dit il est
grand coiffure pas mal de choses merci
je t'ai mis en galère qui la terre sur
bfm
notre d'or philippe était invité jean
jacques bourdin merde oui c'est du
suédois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais la camion vis bien voulu va déjà
devoir nations sont à gstaad premier
ministre salam et du marais un ministre
ou pas il n'est pas passé loin du bourre
pifs j'ai l'impression helder filipe 73
j'avais deux ans je ne souviens pas eu
débat au moment de la ceinture de
sécurité mais vous en souvenez parce que
vous êtes légèrement plus âgés que moi
bah c'est un fait mais vous en souvenez
eficien vous souvenez que ça verts ale
laurie germans merci expliquer sa
politique en chiffres mais il est très
tôt je vous cache pas que des anecdotes
que sainte catherine sur les deux
dernières années il ya eu 2 196 1000
contrôles 296 me contrôler sur trois
millions quatre cent mille ça veut dire
que sur ces 10 % il ya 20 % de gens
pendant 20 % de ces 10% pour qu'elle le
contrôle a été bénéfique
ayez eu quatorze patrons de ce type en
sons qui ont fait l'objet d'une sanction
j'ai enchaîné avec la télé russe
rapidement encore l on a vu kelly qui a
faim duplex sans ses platines
visiblement ya cyril qui était dans son
qui l'avaient accompagné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sortez sortez allez merci
mais pour une fois qu'elle s'amuse
qu'ils soient vus hotyat place au jeu
qu'est ce qui fait un mètre 83 73 kg
qu'un regard de braise et qu'à regarder
le sait y est c'est moi pas mais c'est
vrai bah ouais je me suis rendu matinale
de pascal de la tour du pin mon petit
doigt me dit que son journaliste est pas
prêt de [ __ ] un frein en pierre
bretagne je voulais dire pied est au
courant de cette matinale il neige
également en champagne en touraine
encore en bretagne le finistère sous un
tapis blanc pas si fréquent côté breton
breton par don juan williams à midi
william leymergie et était dans le dur
ce matin il parle normal mais il n'est
plus de voyelles on comprend rien mais
nos périodes télématin été moins crade
as est ce que vous savez faire ça alors
c'est vous le faites chez vous ça
marchera pas et hop la machine à les
lever
paref airs et brax et le le dîner après
le déjeuner débit sitter en urgence
c'est contagieux de ville et apprécié sa
chroniqueuse verica mounier véronique
pendant mon nez qui a pas touchées mais
ripper ou alors ça se passe très bien de
son code source qui renvoyait le courant
électrique à vos muscles qui se
contracte mais en même temps vous allez
faire une vraie séance de porcs de
poules
ça arrivait sur france 3 j'ai regardé
comme une envie de jardin avec un
dresseur qui parle de son célèbre il est
à fond dessus plus que lukasz notre
notre mâle reproducteur est très
important au niveau génétique on est au
niveau européen c'est du change l'image
ça fait tout de suite penser à pau
thannois donc l'année dernière ils
étaient partis en aide aux zones fort
pour pouvoir saillir des femelles là bas
là cette année il est revenue et a
priori il a fait son boulot
j'ai regardé pour la destination alors
qui sait qu'ali moto destination qui
commande c'est mathieu lartot déjà
beaucoup mathieu biron et il a bossé
quand même longtemps a pas se mentir
avec patrick montel au service des
sports patrick pronostics montel ça sert
sentiers dans du dernier match et ben
c'est pas le cas cette année
les maxima chemin en espérant pour lui
porter la poisse
[Applaudissements]
dans la matinale de france info samuel
etienne et nathalie rihouet sont
visiblement très complices
faya samuel qui fait des blagues et
nathalie qui essaie d'enchaîner en
cachant sa ged l'amitié quoi alors c'est
vrai que ces chutes de neige couvre
l'ensemble c'est pas craint qui va de la
normandie jusqu'à l'île de france
au total on attend entre 2 et 5 cm de
neige du côté de tension les sentiments
est important de 5 centimes qu'il est
joueur on a appris que patrick sabatier
revient sur ces 8 et 2000 et qui a
décidé de relancer ce plh sur la chaîne
la valérie bénaïm elle rigole pas elle
s'entraîne tous les après ma la pistache
de la garenne colombes
[Musique]
la garde est il qu'avant mokdad seront
bbc mardi
si j'ai regardé des chiffres et des
lettres aujourd'hui vous avez vous
pouvez adore ça le lot romejko il se
lâche de plus en plus en lui à ses
vannes sur vannes encore un petit jeune
qui va pas tarder à arriver sur ces huit
ça je le sens problème tant des chiffres
et des lettres plus personne fait
semblant de se marrer ac ne va plus
personne n'écoute plus personne
non vous salami que ce qui avait mis
l'an les oiseaux salami comme le nom du
chien c'est cubitus mois à fond à fond à
fond
bon bah écoute et voilà donc pour ce
tirage je suis pris des news de
m'envoyer en préféré c'est guillaume sur
idf org
apparemment sont aussi les médecins
généralistes et du coup ils essaient
d'envoyer tous les gars des consuls chez
lui en vous avez eu des problèmes de
gorge qui ce qui a eu des problèmes de
thyroïde ou de gorge saison je vois
quelque chose votre attention à votre
mâchoire vous avez mal aux dents ou à la
bouche rouge et ce cas je sais pas il ya
au niveau du visage vous n'avez pas
d'éthique ou des problèmes ont mal au
visage non noël enfants de stars grade
et ouais spéciales et michel blanc et un
enfant c'est les yeux de gan et tout le
reste de michel beauregard des
maîtresses il rencontrer facilement des
jeunes à lisieux les échos
les blancs secs cédé 10 ans d'idf1
d'ailleurs on aura jacky qui viendra
nous voir demain on va griller des dsk
qu'ils sont chaudes batailles mokhtar
dans les films art et essai la mare
alexion ça pousse
alors si vous nous rejoignez ça me
rappelle qu'on peut avoir un petit
extrait du film avec plaisir s'appelle
daddy coup d'aile de dx est un vrai rôle
j'ai vu des rôles bien laurence arné de
l'apa le film merci voilà avec la toile
et tout le monde
c'est philippe parent dont le très sympa
est possible c'est une blague
après je comprends pas si débile pas de
punch
enfin mais c'est une musique je vais
l'enlever l'intérieur repas d'abord joué
[Applaudissements]
par la bourgeoise on y croit à mettre au
chaud vachement bien alors donc km ans
on a décidé de le mettre dans plein de
filles très connu pour reprendre les
rôles des classiques du cinéma pour
montrer à tous là tous les directeurs de
casting qui nous regardent que mokhtar
il a sa place dans un western dans un
film d'époque dans un également la
comédie romantique dans les scènes de nu
il est à l'aise dans toutes les matières
regardez mokhtar
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'un humain
certes le net
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu t'es qu'elle
comment oses-tu me tourner le dos
tu va retirer ton casque et le dire
comment tu te nomme
mon nom et mokhtar cubitus uranus agents
de securitas et 8 us au service du vrai
empereur cyril hahn anus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à défaut c'est qu'il a le même prénom
dans tous les films
reste à savoir un camping juste rouge le
brésil à l'aise en bleu
alors on attend moment
[Applaudissements]